Quand un mouvement inclut dans son discours
un langage sur l'égalité des sexes,
cela augmente considérablement ses chances d'adopter la non-violence
et donc la probabilité de succès.
Les recherches sont en accord avec ma propre documentation
de l'organisation politique en Israël et en Palestine.
J'ai remarqué que les mouvements accueillant des femmes dirigeantes,
comme celui que j'ai documenté dans un village appelé Budrus,
avaient plus de chances d'atteindre leurs objectifs.
Ce village était menacé d'être effacé de la carte
quand Israël a construit une barrière de séparation.
Le chemin proposé nécessitait
la destruction des oliveraies et cimetières de la communauté
et finirait par encercler le village.
Grâce à un leadership inspiré,
ils ont lancé une campagne de résistance non-violente pour empêcher cela.
C'était très loin d'être gagné d'avance.
Mais ils avaient une arme secrète :
une fille de 15 ans
qui a courageusement sauté devant un bulldozer
qui allait déraciner un olivier, arrêtant le bulldozer.
A ce moment, la communauté de Budrus a réalisé ce qui était possible
s'ils accueillaient et encourageaient les femmes à participer à la vie publique.
Et donc les femmes de Budrus ont été en première ligne, jour après jour,
utilisant créativité et perspicacité
pour surmonter les multiples obstacles leur faisant face
lors d'une lutte non-armée de 10 mois.
Comme vous vous en doutez sûrement,
elles ont fini par gagner.
La barrière de séparation a été entièrement transformée
en la ligne verte internationalement reconnue
et les femmes de Budrus sont devenues connues
dans toute la Cisjordanie
pour leur énergie indomptable.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Je voulais marquer une pause, et vous m'y avez aidée,
car j'aimerais évoquer deux confusions très sérieuses
pouvant arriver à cet instant.
La première est que je ne crois pas
que les femmes soient intrinsèquement plus pacifiques que les hommes.
Mais je crois que, dans le monde actuel,
les femmes ont une expérience différente du pouvoir.
Ayant eu à naviguer à une position moins puissante
dans de multiples aspects de leur vie,
les femmes sont souvent plus habiles
à subrepticement faire pression pour obtenir un changement
face à des acteurs plus puissants.
Le terme « manipulatrice », souvent utilisé désobligeamment contre les femmes,
reflète une réalité où les femmes doivent souvent trouver d'autres moyens
que la confrontation directe pour accomplir leurs objectifs.
Trouver des alternatives à la confrontation directe
est au cœur de la résistance non-violente.
Maintenant, la seconde confusion potentielle.
J'ai beaucoup parlé de mes expériences au Moyen-Orient
et certains pourraient penser
que la solution est que nous éduquions les sociétés musulmanes et arabes
à plus inclure leurs femmes.
Si nous faisions cela, elles réussiraient mieux.
Elles n'ont pas besoin de ce genre d'aide.
Les femmes ont fait partie des mouvements les plus influents
venant du Moyen-Orient
mais elles tendent à être invisibles pour la communauté internationale.
Nos caméras sont très concentrées sur les hommes
qui sont impliqués dans les scènes plus conflictuelles
et que nous trouvons irrésistibles pour passer à la télé.
Nous finissons avec une histoire qui non seulement efface les femmes
des luttes de la région
mais souvent déforme les luttes elles-mêmes.
A la fin des années 80, un soulèvement a débuté à Gaza
et s'est vite répandu en Cisjordanie et à Jérusalem-Est.
Il s'est fait connaître sous le nom de première Intifada
et les gens qui en ont un souvenir visuel
évoquent en général quelque chose comme ceci :
des hommes palestiniens jetant des pierres sur des tanks israéliens.
La couverture médiatique
faisait croire que les pierres, les cocktails Molotov et les pneus en feu
étaient les seules activités ayant lieu lors de l'Intifada.
Cependant, cette période fut aussi marquée par de larges mouvements non-violents,
sous la forme de grèves, sit-in et la création d'institutions parallèles.
Durant la première Intifada,
des secteurs de la population civile palestinienne se sont mobilisés,
transcendant les générations, factions et classes.
Cela fut fait à travers des réseaux de comités populaires,
l'utilisation d'actions directes et des projets de développement municipal
ont mis au défi la capacité de l'Israël
à continuer de gouverner la Cisjordanie et Gaza.
Selon l'armée israélienne elle-même,
97% des activités de la première Intifada étaient non armées.
Voici autre chose qui ne fait pas partie de notre récit sur cette époque.
Pendant 18 mois de l'Intifada,
les femmes étaient celles qui décidaient en coulisses :
des femmes palestiniennes de tous milieux sociaux
en charge de mobiliser des centaines de milliers de personnes
dans un effort conjoint pour s'extraire de l'occupation.
Naela Ayyash, qui a réussi à bâtir une économie palestinienne auto-suffisante
en encourageant les femmes de Gaza à cultiver des légumes dans leurs jardins,
une activité qui, à l'époque, était jugée illégale par les autorités israéliennes ;
Rabeha Diad, qui a repris en charge l'autorité de prise de décisions
de toute la révolte
quand les hommes qui la dirigeaient
ont été déportés ;
Fatima Al Jaafari, qui a avalé des tracts stipulant les directives de la révolte
afin de les répandre sur les territoires
sans se faire attraper ;
et Zahira Kamal,
qui a assuré la longévité de la révolte
en dirigeant l'organisation
qui, en un an, est passée de 25 à 3 000 femmes.
Malgré leurs accomplissements extraordinaires,
aucune de ces femmes n'est apparue dans notre récit de la première Intifada.
Nous reproduisons cela ailleurs dans le monde.
Dans nos livres d'histoire, par exemple, et dans notre conscience collective,
les hommes sont les visages publics et les porte-parole
de la lutte des années 60 pour la justice raciale aux États-Unis.
Mais les femmes étaient aussi une force motrice cruciale,
mobilisant, organisant, parlant dans les rues.
Combien d'entre nous pensent à Septima Clark
en pensant à l'ère des droits civiques aux États-Unis ?
Très peu.
Mais elle a joué un rôle crucial dans toutes les phases de la lutte,
particulièrement en insistant sur l'alphabétisation et l'éducation.
Elle a été omise, ignorée,
comme tant d'autres femmes qui ont joué des rôles cruciaux
dans le mouvement des droits civiques.
Il n'est pas question d'obtenir le mérite.
C'est plus profond que cela.
Les histoires que nous racontons influencent beaucoup
notre vision de nous-mêmes
et comment nous croyons que les mouvements sont dirigés
et comment les mouvements sont gagnés.
Nos récits d'un mouvement comme la première Intifada
ou l'ère des droits civiques américains
comptent profondément et ont une influence cruciale
sur les choix que feront les Palestiniens,
les Américains
et les peuples à travers le monde
lorsqu'ils rencontreront une injustice
et trouveront le courage de la confronter.
Si nous n'élevons pas les femmes ayant joué des rôles cruciaux dans ces luttes,
nous échouons à offrir des modèles aux générations futures.
Sans modèles, il devient plus difficile
pour les femmes de réclamer la place qui leur revient de droit
dans la vie publique.
Comme nous l'avons vu un peu plus tôt,
une des variables les plus cruciales
pour déterminer si un mouvement sera fructueux ou non
est l'idéologie du mouvement concernant le rôle des femmes
dans la vie publique.
La question est de savoir si nous avançons
vers des sociétés plus démocratiques et pacifiques.
Dans un monde où il y a tant de changements
et où le changement continuera d'arriver à une allure croissante,
il n'est pas question de savoir si nous pouvons faire face à un conflit
mais plutôt
de savoir quelles histoires façonneront
notre façon de gérer les conflits.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)